they arrived at dawn limped their way
into the office of the governor
exhausted
and some too sick to work
they served meals in an office where
normally cabinet meetings are held
with their first decent meals and days
they gathered the strength
to tell us what happened
they drove us like animals some of us
were falling and getting injured
they made us trek for two to three hours
and spent the first two days in the camp
they pushed us forward threatening to
kill anyone who refused to move
despite the blisters on our feet they
forced us to walk further until we
reached the second
and then the third camp the 279 students
were kidnapped while they were sleeping
in their boarding school dormitories
in the town of jangebe in circumstances
similar to the boko haram kidnapping
of more than 270 girls in chibok
in 2014 this man
a former bandit says he left several
others to help bring the girls back
we met and told them we came in peace to
leave with the girls who for no fault of
theirs found themselves
in such a situation they also spoke
about their grievances and why they took
the girls
it was a long difficult process full of
tension but we also came ready and
prepared for the unforeseen
the girls have now been taken to a
secure location for medical examinations
before they are reunited with their
families but that
hasn't stopped excited parents like
nawali uzman to get close to where they
are
my joy is indescribable i called my wife
to tell her the girls are back
i haven't seen my daughter but i'm
relieved she's back the past four days
were traumatic
now we can afford to eat sleep and smile
the governor of zamford state who has
offered amnesty to gunmen who surrender
insists dialogue with the bandits will
continue despite the pitfalls
so it was those that refused that we are
now fighting
and we tell god that we have the content
once
and those repentant ones are working for
us and they are waiting for the
government they are working for the
security
so we're going to continue with that
process because not all of them
that are bad like the one that we use to
secure the release of these children
they are all repentant bundled
because nobody can be able to lease them
the kidnapping of these girls on friday
came hours before the release of another
set of students kidnapped in central
nigeria
the zamfara attack is a sixth mass
school kidnapping
in northern nigeria in recent years with
the girls back
attention is now shifting to the future
of education
with schools continuously being targeted
especially in northern part of nigeria
there are fears
that the region which has the highest
rates of poverty may fall even farther
behind
it's not clear if these girls will have
the courage to return to school
or even if their parents will allow them
to return
but for now they're happy to enjoy their
freedom hoping the government
will do more to protect them
nigeria